rich people have a lot of power one of
the key questions of modern economics
and politics is therefore what are the
rich really want the standard assumption
has tended to be more money but the
reality is stranger and more hopeful
ironically the one thing the rich
generally aren't much motivated by is
money itself they have far more than
enough of that already enough to keep
ten generations going the rich are not
therefore working to make more money
with an eye to spending it they're
making more money in order to keep score
to put it at its simplest in order to be
respected and liked the rich are working
for love and for honor they stay up late
at the office out of vanity because they
want to be able to walk into rooms full
of strangers and be swiftly recognized
by those that matter as miraculous and
clever surveying the problems of
capitalism the standard response of the
left has been to suggest that one should
simply tax the rich more but this fails
to grasp and therefore properly to
exploit the real psychological motives
of the rich the rich only pursue money
frantically to our great collective cost
because wealth appears to be the primary
most objective source of honor in the
modern world but if only we can fix how
honor is obtained we will be able to
redirect their mania to more socially
beneficial ends in ways that work in
sync with their deformed ego driven
personalities at present a natural
inclination is to force the rich to give
up their wealth using the instrument of
new taxes but this strategy is doomed
the chances of people running away and
taking their assets with them is too
great we need to go down a different
route the aim is to seduce the rich to
make them want to benefit their
societies in return for giving them what
we know they deep down really want but
haven't until now reliably been able to
get accept through money namely honor we
know well enough that societies can
motivate people very powerfully through
honor soldiers will perform
extraordinary feats on the battlefield
in return for the highest gratitude from
their countries they don't even ask to
be paid very much scientists will labor
in poverty for decades in the hope of
winning a Nobel
Yetta societies were only just beginning
to explore what good can come out of
vanity in the realm of business in the
commercial world there are at present no
systematic failsafe methods for gaining
status in return for doing what society
desperately needs capitalists to do
treat their work as well and produce
useful safe environmentally sound goods
and services in some countries there may
be the odd hope of a medal from the
president or a royal if one behaves well
but the chances of securing one are
simply too remote and unpredictable to
motivate hard-headed capitalists in
their actions from day to day it remains
far more rational to peg one's hopes for
status on the verifiable criterion of
money rather than on the vague chance of
an invitation from the palace this is
precisely what needs to be changed
society should do a systematic deal with
capitalists it should give them the
honor and laughs they so badly crave in
exchange for treating their workers as
human beings not abusing customers and
properly looking after the planet the
prestige should be enormous a bit like
winning the Nobel Prize the Victoria
Cross or the Pulitzer Prize in other
words a fitting target for capitalists
the most ambitious and narcissistically
Craven and damaged people in any society
the founding figure of modern economics
Adam Smith cleverly recognized the two
chief motivating factors in human life
the love of money and the love of glory
he argued that a wise society must learn
how to harness the love of glory at
times like now when the public good
comes into conflict with a love of
riches we need the energy of
entrepreneurs we need their drive and
determination but if these business
people continue to be motivated by
unchecked profit alone we will all go to
ruin to solve the problem we don't have
to wait until the rich miraculously grow
magnanimous or kind we should target the
vanity of the rich and encourage them to
act well from that most powerful of
desires that desire to be loved it will
be a very small price to pay in return
for a more humane version of capitalism
you